comme à chaque année on vous présente
les tendances technos notre invité cette
année c'est pascal forget chroniqueur
techno à l'émission planète techno sur
ici explorer bonsoir bonsoir merci
beaucoup d'être d'être avec nous de nous
présenter cela il ya vraiment des choses
très intéressantes les passions parlait
beaucoup de google
et cette année on parle plus
d'accessoires connecter un oui parce que
beaucoup de gens qui ont reçu un google
on l'an passé qu'ils ont utilisés comme
un peu de plaisir pendant quelques jours
mais après un goûter demandé à google
compte moins de blague
quelle est la météo nouvelle toro cela
ça prendre la poussière et l'eau
peut-être que cette année on peut donner
des cadeaux qu'ils vont bonifier son
goût gollum son assistant vocal
personnel avec des accessoires qui sont
connectés il ya des actions tout simple
comme des ampoules
oui des ampoules qui sont compatibles
avec google ont donc on peut parler
alan poul pour l'allumer changer sa
luminosité la luminosité et ça c'est
absolument fantastique une fois qu'on ya
goûté on peut aller plus loin que ça
sent le déjà des lumières dans la maison
on veut pas tout les remplacer
nécessairement on peut aussi utiliser
des interrupteurs qui sont connectés
voiliers qui sont compatibles avec
google et avec aussi l'assistant
personnel échos d'amazon
donc on peut entrer dans la pièce et
changer l'intensité de ses lumières qui
sont connectés dans le mur il ya même
pour des objets qui sont pas encore
connectés on pense par exemple à
quelqu'un qui était mobilité réduite une
personne âgée peut être qu'il veut pas
nécessairement se lever pour allumer ou
éteindre sa radio peut brancher sa dans
un petit texte ce soir une petite prise
de courant tout à fait standard oui mais
qui est compatible avec les assistants
personnels dont on vous parle à sa prise
de court par la sa prise de courant
allumer et éteindre n'importe quel
appareil ça peut être le chauffage la
voiture l'imagination des gens tout ce
que vous pouvez brancher là dedans peut
être contrôlée par la voix allumées et
éteintes et c'est super pratique et
poitrey chance a fait des beaux cadeaux
pour les amateurs de technique savent
pas trop quoi faire
ouais faut quand même vérifier faut
s'assurer que les appareils sont
compatibles avec l'assistant clair son
acquisition parce que les sites en
personnel
golo mais aussi écoute d'amazon donc si
on achète des produits beaucoup de
produits qui sont connectés j'ai montré
sur tp link qui sont compatibles avec
les deux et si vous achetez un appareil
connecté assurez vous de vérifier chez
la personne qui est ce qu'ils ont à la
maison pour que ce soit bien compatible
à l'ère des objets connectés on peut
rendre sa télé intelligente ce qui est
pas de mauvaises choses on peut chercher
du contenu avec sa voix également alors
comment ça fonctionne comme ça que c'est
le fun qui vit alexa edition le chili a
activé des chocs est compatible avec
l'assistant personnel
alexandre d'amazon donc on peut parler à
son téléviseur pour demander du contenu
donc on peut demander
montre moi l'émission planète techno par
exemple pour kung fu et surtout bon et
tv pour trouver les missions la techno
ou rdi économie où l économie marocaine
ici c'est le temps des fêtes la
réconciliation des familles c'est pour
ça mais on peut le faire en parlant sa
télécommande donc n'ont pas besoin
d'avoir un assistant personnel qui était
allumée en permanence chez soi si on
branche l'assistant son téléviseur quand
on était son téléviseur son assistant
personnel ne fonctionne plus et ça ça
permet aussi de parler à son téléviseur
pour allumer les lumières les analysant
pour le connecter on peut les allumer un
parent sa télécommande de son territoire
est pauvre il atterrit vos réponses
quand j'étais petit la télé une réponse
mais on a un vrai pas vraiment lui
parler et ça permet aussi sondé des
caméras de surveillance de voir dans son
téléviseur
qu'est ce qui se passe on entend un
bruit si on veut voir qui sont les
invités qui arrive sur un système
compatible on peut tout simplement
demandé montre moi ma caméra de
surveillance
et boum on voit dans son téléviseur
qu'est ce qui était inscrit c'est un
tout petit appareil qui coûte une
cinquantaine de dollars parfait nouveau
téléphone one classe ou 1 6t un
téléphone android pour ceux qui veulent
beaucoup aujourd'hui je veux un appareil
photo je prends les plus belles photos
parce qu'il voit des photos des
influenceurs sur instagram est stricte
ya des appareils sont fantastiques
le médecin paul iphone
les appareils de samsung très très bon
très bonne caméra mais le moins de plus
et moins cher et iodée très bonne caméra
à l'arrière deux caméras on peut zoomer
et surtout on a la reconnaissance
d'empreintes digitales sur l'écran donc
au lieu de chercher un petit capteur à
l'arrière on peut tout simplement
appuyer sur l'écran est un espèce
d'effet qui est assez magique et qui
j'espère va fonctionner magie du direct
enfin l'espèce des clercs le vu
brièvement et ça permet de déverrouiller
son appareil simplement en appuyant avec
le pose avec le pouce sur l'écran c'est
très con bien technologies c'est autour
de ce sens quelques dollars donc c'est
presque la moitié du prix des appareils
haut de gamme avec des performances très
très très similaires beaucoup de
stockage ainsi tué l'inconvénient c'est
qu'il faut l'acheter en ligne
donc il faut faire un acte de foi il est
pas disponible en magasin ils font des
très bons appareils et c'est très
agréable
les écouteurs sans fil grosse tendance
parce que les compagnies 57 en écoutant
pour les ados ça c'est un écouteur plus
peut-être trop monsieur madame tout le
monde c'est la même compagnie one plus
qui fait un appareil un appareil sans
fil compose en plaçant son coup donc on
le perd pas ouais ça coûte 100 dollars
canadiens très sympathique ont les mains
en menant son coup quand il est connecté
comme ça il était temps oui quand on
veut répondre à un épais quand on écoute
la musique on est des tâches on pose le
bouchon à ses oreilles ça tombe on ne
peut rien et c'est fantastique on peut
courir avec ça on peut courir son désir
mais l'effet que sa bouche les oreilles
c'est pour être l'agent de sécurité dans
tout juste du bon succès des appareils
pour monsieur maintenant ça c'est pour
les ados qui veulent des écouteurs sans
fil des écouteurs de gamer c'est la
compagnie hype rex qui fait ça sont
vraiment pas cher et sont faits pour
résister aux colères des gamer donc les
dons qui sont résistants pour des ados
c'est important parce que si l'ado ou
décide d'être fâché de le laisser tomber
voilà il va aux prises instantanément et
vous vous dites sûrement mais j'ai pas
le but d'avoir un gros micro comme ça
devant moi ça c'est pratique pour ceux
qui font du jeu en ligne pour parler à
leurs adversaires exact nous en servir
pour faire des appels téléphoniques mais
aussi tout simplement les détacher a
fini micron qui ont vu se promener dans
la rue avec ça et c'est une marque qui
écoule les jeunes aiment ça parce que
c'est une marque d'accessoires de jeux
vidéo
donc c'est une macro bien
c'est environ 200 dollars g vérifiant la
ligue en ce moment ils sont tous vendus
parce que je pense que c'est une période
qui est intéressant aucun site en
aluminium c'est bien sûr the hills si on
apparaît des idées de cadeaux éducatifs
et québécois aussi quelque chose
antidote je vais en parler parce que
c'est la dixième édition d'antidote
cédric au recteur donner à quelqu'un
le cadeau de faire moins de fautes c'est
fantastique absolument et la nouvelle
édition est super facile à utiliser et
les médecins utilisable en ligne donc
nous prenons ça aura besoin de
l'installer dans son appareil on peut se
connecter
on ne peut pas besoin de l'installer
dans sa machine on peut l'utiliser sur
une tablette dans une interface en ligne
donc ça peut sauver sa vie si on veut
pas nécessairement l'installer dans son
appareil et on peut aussi acheter
tap'touche hapkido un produit québécois
la compagnie de rideau si oui c'est un
logiciel qui est vieux comme tout qui
permet d'apprendre à taper cette année
vous pouvez l'acheter en ligne donc pour
moyens mais si vous avez la boîte la
boîte se transforme en cash pour que la
vie donc vous mettez pour les enfants
pour les adultes vous ne voyez par vous
même et vous apprenez à taper dans cette
petite boîte qui se transforme en cash
c'est un code maintenant ne pas besoin
de la boîte son village dans la ligne
mais je trouvais que l'idée de vraiment
génial va voir de transpirer motivant au
procès doit durer noir prendre et à
payer sa pression il faut contacter plus
vite sans faire de faute
c'est ingénieux une idée pour les
cyclistes
c'est une langue qui s'appellerait
joliette label lights qui pour augmenter
la sécurité c'est un phare à vélo ou
blain donc un phare avant qui est très
puissant mais c'est aussi ça projette
aussi à l'avant je sais pas si on peut
le voir mais ça projette en vélo pour y
est donc ça projette devant soi un vélo
sur la vente ici comme ça la magie des
démos en direct - c'est en tout cas on
voit sur la route si on le projette
quand il fait sombre
oui on peut voir un gros vélo vert
clignoter donc les automobilistes vont
voir un vélo mais vont aussi voir une
grosse forme ouverte 2,20 saisir j'ai
trouvé que c'était très intéressant pour
augmenter la visibilité surtout que les
craintes fait sombre plus tôt je vous
parie du pain faict bec
gros coup car les gens qui font de la
cuisine mais qui ont tendance à oublier
des ingrédients qui sont distraits je
pensais pas que ça fonctionnait aussi
bien ça barde un truc d'infos mercialys
et une balance qui connecter son
téléphone intelligent à sa tablette en
oui les instructions on ouvre on veut
faire un gâteau par exemple on dit que
c'est à dire qu'on veut faire un gâteau
on nous dit de poser le bol ouais et on
sent pas longtemps se mesurer on n'a
qu'à verser les ingrédients dans le bol
on nous dit de changer de bol on met
l'autre bol ont dit de verser les
ingrédients donc la farine lait sur
l'écran sur des téléphones savoir
richard haas l'étape de la recette et ça
nous dit quand arrêter ce qui est
magique section en un peu trop son et
maladroit quand même un peu trop ils
vont nous dire de réajuster les
ingrédients au besoin et c'est assez
précis pour mesurer la pincée de sel et
une goutte de venir moi ça m'a surpris
j'ai un très bon biscuits avec son accès
excellent vous auriez dû les apporter
parce qu'elle courait merci beaucoup
très intéressant pour vos conseils cette
année merci pascal merci bien